time being 10:08 we'll get start
started and
um I want to thank uh representative
Malloy for filling in today on the clerk
duties and um first up we have uh
Department of
Safety ready
[Music]
good morning when you're ready if you'd
introduce yourselves thank
you good
morning my name is Amy newbur and I'm
the director of administration at the
department of safety and with me today
is Jennifer Hall she is the bureau chief
of the Bureau of Road tool within the
department of safety and the division of
administration and today we're
presenting an overview of the highway
fund the unrestricted Revenue
Collections and so today I'm going to
start um excuse me um represent Aly did
you have a question yes on could you
repeat that very slowly the names
because we don't have the names here of
course so I'm Amy
Newbery you might want to just pull that
yeah slightly closer to you I'm director
of administration at the department of
safety and with me is Jennifer Hall and
she's the bureau chief of Road
tool so thank you so
on on page two of your power Point
you'll find an overview of the
Department of Safety the mission and the
vision statement as well as the
organizational structure and so while
you see all seven divisions listed today
we're really going to focus on the
division of administration which is
where the road tool Bureau is and the
Division of Motor Vehicles and as far as
how we're going to present today I'm
going to start with an overview of the
of a revenue it's kind of a summary of
the highway revenue and then Jennifer is
going to speak to the road toll Bureau
and then we're going to stop and take a
pause and answer all of your questions
on the road toll Bureau um Revenue
Collections and then I'll go into the um
Division of Motor
Vehicles so if on page three we want to
highlight the two primary sources of
unrestricted funding for the Department
of Safety Highway funds and General
funds the highway funds totaling
approximately
263 million are generated through a
variety of revenue streams these include
States gas tax collected through the
road tool Bureau as well as Motor
Vehicle registrations driver licenses
motor vehicle certificates of
title vehicle inspections and other
miscellaneous
revenues so let's begin by discussing
Highway funds if you turn to page
five you'll see the total Highway funds
collected in fiscal year
2024 amounted to
263.net projection of
29.9 Million by 4 million for fiscal
year
2025 we're projecting Highway fund
Revenue collections of
2612 million which is approximately
800,000 more than the planned
26.4
million while Highway fund revenues have
seen a modest annual growth rate of
0.51% between 2018
and fiscal year
2024 this increase has not kept pace
with the rising cost that these revenues
are intended to support These funds are
critical for supporting the department
of transportation's work on New
Hampshire roads as well as uh several
key functions within the department of
safety including the division of State
Police and the commissioner's
office this gap between revenue and
growth and cost increases
has resulted in structural deficits
within the highway
fund Revenue are the revenues are no
longer sufficient to meet the operating
needs for which the fund was
designed to address the shortfall you
may remember that between fiscal year 22
and 23 by Anum the legislature
transferred 50 million in general funds
and an additional 10 million was
transferred in fiscal year 2425 bym to
ensure that it could balanced for the
upcoming
bium now I want to turn things over to
Jennifer Hall bureau chief of Road tool
who will share more details about the
road tool
operations thank you
Amy the road tool operations um consist
primarily of collecting the motor fuel
tax um we call it the road toll um and
we also enforce compliance through our
field audit division within the
bureau the rooto law is not related to
the toos on the turnpike that's a common
misconception we get calls all the time
asking if they can pay off their Easy
Pass balance um so we're completely
separate um that system is operated by
the department of
transportation we administer
approximately 153 motor fuel distributor
licenses 61 motor fuel transporter
licenses
1679 International fuel tax agreement
licenses and 229 oil discharge and
Pollution Control
licenses we turn to slide
seven the point of Taxation for our
motor fuel tax or road toll here in New
Hampshire is at the distributor
distributor letter level so the product
comes in to terminals we have some
terminals here in New Hampshire um or it
will come in by truck from out of state
um but it must be a distributed to a
licensed distributor and then through
their filings with road toll they tell
us where that product goes and the
taxability of that product so some of
the
um transactions that occur that make it
a tax-free event are sales to other
licensed distributors or sales outside
of the State of New Hampshire so if they
export the product they get the credit
on that road
tool um and that's pretty much it for
the you know once they drop the product
into the retail station that is a
taxable event and then the road tool is
collected at that point based on that
distribution turn to slide
eight factors impacting the estimates
for road toll price
um after reaching a high of
4.99 6 cents per gallon in June of 22
gas prices have declined and seem to
have
stabilized for now um according to triaa
the average price per gallon in New
Hampshire as of January 28th is 2.97 4
cents per gallon and this is down the
slide says up but that should actually
say down um 076 cents from last year's
average of 3.05 cents per
gallon the US Energy Information
Administration forecasts motor gasoline
prices to decline um from the average of
3.2 cents per gallon and 25 to 3.02
cents per gallon in
26 the Energy Information Administration
also expects crude oil prices to average
$72 per barrel in both 25 and fall to 64
um dollars per barrel in
26 the weather impacts um our income for
um fuel tax dry Summers and snowy
Winters help to drive our tourism in New
Hampshire and that increases our fuel
consumption
here um a lack of snow or warm
temperatures in the winter months um
results in lower fuel consumption in the
winter the economy the US Department of
Commerce and the Bureau of economic Al
analysis
um The Real gross domestic product has
increased at a rate of 3.1% in the third
quarter of 24 and in the second quarter
of 24 it increased at a rate of
3.0% um the US Labor Bureau of Labor
Statistics reported in January of 25
that the Consumer Price Index for all
items Rose
2.9% from December of 23 to December of
24 so those are all um factors that can
impact our income on the road
tool and then on page nine we just have
a graph of um past historical revenue
and expected revenue for um fy2 through
FY
27 um in fiscal year 24 we collected
127.5 million in revenues which was 2.9
Million more than the planned 125
million in FY 25 we're projecting to
collect about
[Music]
127.71 million from the planned 125.638
over on the right hand side at the
bottom of the graph there for
you and I guess at this point we'll
pause and take questions related to the
road tool
operations yes represent elberger thank
you Mr chair and thank you for taking my
question um can you just uh expound a
little bit on the
IFA something I have not heard about
okay yes so the international fuel tax
agreement page six is um an additional
license that um carriers who haul um
using vehicles that weigh over 26,000
pounds or have three or more um axles so
the heavier vehicles that are putting
more wear and tear on the road have to
obtain an additional license um and we
administer those license so they they
used to be uh it used to be that they
would have to get permits for each
jurisdiction um to travel through and
pay the appropriate tax to use the roads
in those Juris sections the
international fuel tax agreement has
made it um more Consolidated so they can
pick a homebased state and just file
their um mileage and fuel usage per
jurisdiction to that home base State and
then that base State um disperses the
tax to the other jurisdictions that the
carrier traveled in based on a pro-rated
system thank you thank
you um I'll just guest ask a question on
page six also those um
licenses are those all yearly renewals
um all except for the oil discharge and
pollution control license that one is
Perpetual until they no longer need the
license so it's a one-time fee okay uh
well so they pay um monthly fees based
on the products that they're selling so
they file monthly reports and pay fees
based on that but there's no actual
licensing fee on top of that they just
pay into um the funds that the oil
discharge and Pollution Control license
um collects for thank you representa
ery yeah just to warm the oil pollution
that goes into a dedicated fund uh does
it not and that's for remediation
correct so it doesn't affect the general
fund monies correct direct completely
separate and that's handled through
Department of Environmental Services and
then you take from that if oh and an
eror mate takes place someplace and
there's a leak and you use that to to
mitigate yeah just so that we understand
that
yep representative Spar thank you Mr
chair um I'm new to the committee and I
I was just on if I understood you you
said that in 2023 the general fund gave
50 million to cover uh uh the costs that
were not that exceeded revenues and you
said 2024 is 10 million uh just so I
understand historically is is it usually
uh or is an objective of of the
department to to be self-sufficient what
what's what what's sort of the objective
and or
expectation as far as I'm aware that was
the first time those transfers had
happened it's that the expenses have um
the revenue has not kept up with the
increasing expenses against the highway
fund follow and when the revenues do
exceed the expenditures for the year
what happens to those excess funds do
they stay in the department do they go
back to the general fund how does that
work do you
know so if there's
any unexpended Appropriations that laps
back to the highway funds because these
Highway funds dollars expenditure if
their expenditures are exceeding the
revenue
they would need to make adjustments
within the department to adjust for that
so they may decrease some of the
activities that they're doing or they
need to get more Revenue added to
their to go supplemental bill that but
so for the most part the department
doesn't have an issue when you give them
the budget having not enough funds for
that the highway fund sits over here
from that Highway fund several
departments benefit from those revenues
they budget their expenditures based on
what they believe those
does that help followup
you okay um representative Brier yeah
thank you Mr chairman thank you for
taking my question
um first question I had is uh could you
give me an update on the DED fuel
enforcement uh program and how that's
going and what the status of that is
uh yeah we just recently hired um a
fulltime well a part-time uh fuel
enforcement officer so that we can um
you know better address the concerns
with um inappropriate use of dyed fuel
um proper taxation of of the fuel being
used in vehicles on the roadway so he
just barely started um I
believe on Friday in this position so
we're working to get him up to speed
follow uh the other thing I remember is
um uh I'm assuming you're still
utilizing the IRS to do your died fuel
sampling currently yes Y and I was
curious of um is there any possibility
and that probably uh have to be a
discussion with uh State Police is there
any possibility of uh moving some of
that died fuel testing into the state's
forensic lab to uh kind of make the make
it a little more efficient for road to
to get the testing results
back thank you for the question it's not
a current conversation but it's
certainly something we could
explore okay thank you one more follow
uh were you able to uh fill all your
audit positions before the hiring
free the audit
positions um all the ones that were
posted have we have no vacancies that
we're looking for in the AUD time that's
good to hear thank you yes represent BS
thank you Mr chairman excuse me uh
thanks for taking my question so how
much fuel does the average vehicle use a
year you're asking for fuel consumption
or Road tool on average my my thought is
if it was 1,000 gallons the average
vehicle would use would donate to the
state $22 in taxes if I did the math in
my head correctly so our estimat did I
say 22 220 $220 in taxes so I'm thinking
the electric vehicles are only paying a
$100 sirar charge hybrids 50 maybe we
need to consider raising that if we need
Revenue I mean they're their use on the
roads I think the average electric
vehicle weighs 3,000 lbs more than than
a fuel powered vehicle so maybe that's
something we need to consider so we did
do estimates when the bill was um being
proposed for the registration fees um
and used you know um an average vehicle
average
mpg um I think it was 12,000 miles per
year um and it worked the the numbers
worked out to $112 and some change
annually in the road toll amount so
that's that's how they came up with the
$100 registration fee very good closer
than I would have guessed thank
you okay thank you you may proceed oh
did you have okay
okay you were yes any possibility that
you could get back about the
lab doing died field test
thing okay thank
you nine and 11 look
similar let's now discuss DMV revenues
which are a key component to the highway
fund so on
let me see on page
11 on page 11 you'll see that motor
vehicle registration Revenue in 20 in
fiscal year 24 we collected 93.1 million
which was 2.9 Million above our planned
Target of 90.2 million looking ahead
we're projecting 90.4 million in revenue
for fiscal year 20
five these figures represent the state's
share of registration fees which are
collected at the by the state and
deposited directly into the highway fund
it's in it's important to note that
while we're seeing a dip in Motor
Vehicle registrations year-to date this
could be due to a combination of factors
this could include economic conditions
demographic shifts potential policy
changes or the rise in alternative
transportation op options and increasing
environmental
conditions as as we continue to monitor
these Trends we'll be able to better
understand the impact on future Revenue
projections if we turn to page uh before
if if you don't mind I do have a
question here representative
ery you mentioned that collecting DMV
taxes at the local um um town clerk's
office and the way I understand that and
correct if I'm wrong that is a um a fee
is paid by the
registrant vehicle owner to the town
clerk for the privilege of doing it in
their town uh then there's a fee paid to
the state and then there's a fee paid so
there's a it's a three component uh tax
is that correct or fee fee the and the
part that I'm reporting on is only the
state share going into the highway fund
right so the this the numbers you're
giving us are monies that are going into
the general fund not minus any
percentage going to the town correct
yeah just wanted to it's the highway
fund going into the highway fund
yep represent
elme thank
you I believe I'm remembering correctly
um
we quite a long time ago now we changed
the registration requirement from four
years to five
years and and one of the effects of that
was that every fifth year there would be
a dip is this dip still
occurring the dip is still occurring and
I'm going to get to the um the impact of
that and when we'll start actually
seeing that dip um
fade oh there is um I'm sorry we we seem
to have a couple more
questions there there's a I will get um
repres resentative Aly there's a slide
on that and I'll get to I'll get back to
your question but that is also a factor
oh okay representative elberger thank
you Mr chair thank you for taking my
question uh the little chart at the uh
on the bottom right corner on page
11 uh indicates registration fees and
I'm
hoping that the second line goes from 0
to 3,000 then 3,000 1 to, 1500 I assume
that's a typo oh I apologize I will
follow up thank you I think it's
5,000 yes no 5,000
one uh representative you set seeing
that we cracked a seal here I I thank
you Mr chairman thank you for taking my
question I'm wondering if you're taking
into account and I'm just kind of
thinking about this I know my vehicles
are getting older whether this accounts
for a lot more older vehicles being
registered where that fee goes down have
you taken a look at what that impact may
or may not be in relation to what you
predict forward you bring up a good
point it very well could be good
point um I just I just had someone point
out that may be the town tax portion
that goes down and not the not the state
uh yes
represent yes
just again break that down there's a tax
which is which the number she's
reporting here then there's a fee which
is paid to the town and that is a
sliding scale fee based upon vehicle age
and weight and all that stuff and then
there's another fee for the privilege of
not having to go up and bother the
people and conquered when you register
or pay state tax so one tax and two fees
three charges one
bill okay fromi thank you uh I've been
here a long
time and when I started we were engaged
in increasing or rather when we started
up ways and means again um we were
engaged in increasing the um this tax
and every time we did
this the trucking industry would come in
and would argue us into cutting in half
the increase for
them and after um we did that they would
go to the Senate and get the other half
taken
off so I wasn't I am not now and I was
not then sure whether we
were uh writing a wrong for the trucking
industry or whether we were just being
taken uh do you have any idea what the
relationship is now between the fees
which I don't think have gone up since
about eight years into that
period so about 20 years
ago no I am not aware
thank yes represent opal thank you Mr
chairman and um thank you director
Newber I'm sure we'll let you get back
to the rest of your presentation just
shortly um I I just have a quick
question of course that you may or may
not have handy um on that same page that
representative Elber was talking about
slide 11 that chart the registration
fees I'm wondering if you could provide
us information on the percentage or or
the gross number whichever makes more
sense for each of those weight
categories so that we have some
idea so of the registration fees what
percentage are in the 0 to 3,000 pounds
category what percentage are in the
3,000 to 3,000 to1 to I'm assuming
5,000 Etc through all the
categories I will follow up with the DMV
thank you
okay seeing no more questions you may
continue what now you have a question
yeah yeah all one one more question of
course what the
hey or straw depending upon the time of
year
um nothing in this gives us any idea of
the total number of vehicles that are on
our highways On Any Given because we're
a tourist state is that
correct I do not have that
information and the follow the the other
answer other followup would be if I may
followup there's no way to get that
information unless we surveyed every
single day
correct yes the answer is
yes okay you may may continue please
on page 12 and representative Aly this
gets to your question um motor vehicle
operator revenues which include driver
licenses have stabilized these revenues
have experienced cyclical dips due to
the transition from four to fiveyear
licenses but we anticipate that these
dips will level out by
2036 effective May of 202 5 is the
federal deadline for real ID compliance
which may also Drive additional activity
as individuals upgrade their
licenses on page
14 inspection revenues which follow a by
annual fee structure remains steady at
around 4 million in one year and 3.9 the
next page 15 plea by mail was added to
the highway Fund in fiscal year
20 in fiscal year 24 we collected 5.6
million Which is 682,000 less than the
plan of 6.3 million in fiscal year 25 we
are projecting to collect 5.8 million
which is a decrease of 514
th000 and finally on page
17 while general fund revenues are not a
major Focus they total around 8 million
annually these revenues have decreased
over time as certain functions such as
mechanical licensing has transitioned to
other departments in oplc now um and
therefore the appropriation went as well
in summary while these revenue streams
are stable the modest growth we are
seeing is not sufficient to fully
address rising cost and structural
deficits in the highway funds factors
such as fuel prices economic conditions
and weather patterns will continue to
play a significant role in shaping our
Revenue projections strategic planning
and ongoing legislative support will be
critical and ensuring sustainability of
these funds and programs they support we
welcome your
questions
represent thank you on the plea by May
uh in 20 when we transferred that over
to uh the highway fund the next estimate
was a real guess because we had no idea
how that would actually work out and it
seems as though the the fees have been
pretty much evenly between five and six
each year uh on both uh both counts
however there seems to be a a general
decrease in the um
um overall
amount um received in fees and there is
an increase as you can tell because you
drove to work this morning
in um speeding and in individual
accidents uh accidents with injuries
while deaths have uh uh continue to
decline because of safer cars and the
newer cars I I would presume uh the
enforcement seems to decrease is this
because of a lack of filled positions
within uh the state police division or
uh can you have an idea as to why there
hasn't been uh an increase when there's
been an increase in speeding uh and
other violations I mean you had that
perfect one in Dairy with the school bus
violation um is there anything like that
you could add to that yeah you know I
don't um you know it's it's definitely
not a onetoone I wouldn't say that um
we're actively filling State Police
vacancies we but we do have a high
vacancy rate we're at 61 vacancies right
now um however we are filling um Academy
classes um at between 8 and 10 right now
which is which is really really good um
that that's that's a really good ratio
for us um um so we are recruiting more
we're having more um larger classes um
but as far as writing tickets it's not
the only thing the state police does so
if we were to increase the police force
by 10 we'd probably write more tickets
if we increase by one I don't know um so
I think that um we're going they're
doing the best that they can and we we
have we we don't have we're not fully
staffed so
H and just for the record because PE
some people one or two possibly are
actually watching this there is no quot
system in the State Police or any of the
towns in which you know because the
towns do not receive any of this
money uh and there's no um mandatory
minimum or places where people have to
uh sit and and do traffic enforcement is
that correct to the rest of your
knowledge that's
correct yes
Elber thank you Mr chair thank you for
taking my question uh on slide
17 um there's a uh an indication here
that the purple represents plumbers and
gas
Fitters we haven't G
there I'm
so that with that is a service that's
the licensing service that moved from
safety to um oplc that's the licensing
Fe so the so that is being recorded in
Revenue but just not from
safety just follow
so plumbers and gas Fitters fees used to
come okay thank
you represent op
thank you Mr chairman and thank you
again director um on page 12 again I
would be curious to see if you could
provide us with a
breakdown
um a similar chart over time in terms of
the actually the aggregate numbers of
people who are getting operators
licenses the real ID licenses commercial
you know um I'd be interested I'm
assuming that now when most people are
getting their license renewed they're
getting real ID but um I'd like to I'd
be curious about
that thank you I will follow up with the
DMV as well I'm gonna go over here
first representative
Brier yeah uh I I know you're not going
to have this answer right now but I was
just curious because I haven't looked at
it in a while uh my understanding is uh
New Hampshire is the lowest tax rate on
fuel in the
Northeast uh if you we looked at uh New
England or the Northeast uh what are the
neighboring states rates and uh is there
like how much how many cents are we
lower than say massachus it's Maine
Vermont all the neighboring states
because I if I recall you're still
taking about 830 million gallons taxable
right your taxable gallons is still
about 830 million
ion yeah we haven't seen fluctuation in
that number so he's still bringing about
8 8.3 million for every penny
right so I was just curious uh what we
had for wiggle run between tax rates on
neighboring states um I do have that
breakdown I don't I didn't bring it with
you I didn't expect you to have it I was
just wondering if there possibility to
get with all our neighboring states both
Diesel and gasoline sure
representative
Bolton thank you Mr chair so you
mentioned that you have 61 vacancies
right now um in your police force now we
we heard I guess um uh at least the town
of Plymouth um that there was like a 28%
or 26% vacancy rate is that still the
case or are we hiring
now I don't have the percentage that
seems really high yeah um so so I know
for in State Police we have 61 vacancies
today is it 51 or 61 61 yeah
okay if you drive by follow up sorry if
you drive by um Hazen Drive you'll see
um basically a lot of cars just park
there and I'm not certain if that
reflects why the um the number of
vacancies are still there or something
or
some of the vehicles that you're seeing
are um some of the new vehicles that
have come in that are ready um for upfit
and then deployment because we have a
lot of older vehicles that we are um
transitioning and then some of the other
vehicles that you're seeing are being
prepped um to go out for
auction representative
y lots of questions were raised here um
when the vehicle goes vehicle from
Highway or from State Police or
from um
Dees do we have any record of how much
money is made from that as an
offset when a vehicle goes out to
auction yeah it would be with the
Department of administrative Services
yes
okay okay so that that money is
accounted for someplace yes yeah all
right thank you uh the follow yeah
follow well second question if you all
right yeah um regarding the license fees
your basic operator license costs $50 an
endorsement for motorcycles only I think
another $10 on top of that an
endorsement for commercial license is
then uh depending upon each endorsement
they pay a fee So when you say
commercial is $60 that's 50 plus plus
plus plus it could be 70 or $80 if he's
a a Class A driver with hazardous
materials
endorsement um each endorsement has its
own fee that's attached so that's not
exactly a a set fee not every truck
driver is paying $60 for his truck
license it depends on what he's hauling
um the same thing applies for real ID
because the real ID can apply to a
non-driver ID so that you get $10 for
the non-driver ID which is basically the
cost of the photograph but then there's
the cost of having to do the background
check to get the real ID which is
separate from the endorsement that show
or the uh Little Star that shows up on
the license is that correct I believe
that's correct I want to confirm with
DMV yeah and so this
is a good
generalization but it doesn't provide a
a precise accounting for
each value per uh license uh for example
a uh a Class B Li commercial license
costs less than a Class A commercial
license and then you have school bus
drivers which have to have an operator's
license in order to get a commercial
license so everybody's got to have the
basic license and that is duplicated in
the commercial license uh whether it's
uh for the the heavy trucks or for the
light trucks that that's correct so
knowing each number you're going to get
a you're not going to get an accurate
picture as to the number of drivers that
are on the road is that correct I'm
going to have to defer to the DMV and
get back with you thank
you thank you Mr chair thank you thanks
for taking my
question apologize if this isn't the
right
um organization I'm curious to know what
is the lifespan of a cruiser years and
uh what it's miles um so we um ideally a
replacement plan for um a state police
vehicle we'd want to um we'd be looking
at right around 150,000
miles thank you welcome and there're
good buys at that
okay uh any other qu are you finished or
did you have another slide NOP okay um
any more
questions okay thank you uh is that part
of we have one more okay on the um in
addition to your PowerPoint there is a
one pager for and this these are all the
numbers put together that um is on one
page that are throughout your PowerPoint
as well
thank you very
much we've got a few minutes our next uh
presentation is Department of
Transportation at 11: a.m. so take a few
minutes
for
e
e e
again with the Department of
Transportation welcome thank you very
much Mr chairman for the record my
name's David rodrig I'm the assistant
commissioner and chief engineer of the
Department of Transportation with me is
Danielle Shand Danielle and I'm the uh
Director of Finance
welcome so we've prepared a presentation
for you that I'll go over rather quickly
and we'll be happy at the chair's
pleasure to take questions at the end or
or as you like from a financial
perspective this this presentation more
focuses on a very small amount of our
funds which is the
unrestricted um miscellaneous Revenue
that the department receives but we're
happy to answer any questions that you
have on the on the revenue and how the
Department's funded from a mission and
purpose perspective Ive the department
of transportation's mission is
transportation Excellence enhancing the
quality of life in New Hampshire and we
are very focused on providing a quality
well-maintained
efficient and reliable transportation
system for all our customers that
includes the the people on the highways
and the people on the buses and we do
have one Community train as as well some
key facts about the department we have
about 1,
1650 permanent positions we maintain
about
2159 State Bridges um not under our
maintenance responsibility but Bridges
we do look after and inspect the
municipal Bridges across the state
there's
1,698 of those all bridges are inspected
every two years and red lless Bridges or
bridges that are found to be
structurally deficient that we have
concerns about those are inspected more
frequently than every 2 years some more
key facts we have about 4600 cine cerine
miles of roadway that we manage um we
try to pave about 500 miles of that
pavement a year to keep that in good and
fair condition we maintain more than
100,000 highway signs 68 mlion F feet of
striping 440 traffic signals um also 25
publicly accessible airports and we send
funds to 11 local public transit systems
from a funding summary perspective the
our our fiscal year
2024 actual expenditures were $72
million we break that up in the pie
chart below to to show you of that 300
of that $72 million 396 million of it
flows through us to municipalities for
their um Road Aid and also goes to
construction a capital construction
projects that the larger contractors do
on our roads around the
state we have several divisions in the
department we have the division of
Aeronautics rail in transit um we have a
bureau of Aeronautics a buau bureau of
rail and public transit um the
Aeronautics folks have 25 open to the
public airports 12 of which are
federally funded and 12 of which do not
receive um Federal Aid on the rail side
we have six Active operator agreements
we have 194 miles of active state-owned
Rail lines and 333 miles of abandoned or
inactive Rail
lines on the public transit side we have
11 local public transit systems that run
inner city and commuter services and
provide Community
Transportation some accomplishments
include administration of the federal
funding um Department of departmental U
s that's our drone implementation and
integration and establishment of
relationships with other state agencies
as it deals with um unmanned aircraft or
or
drones we have our finance and
administration divisions the division of
finance um works with our budget
formulation uh Financial operations
contract management overseas our federal
program management financials it takes
care of our debt service and Reporting
and auditing our division of
administration includes our
commissioner's office and the division
of policy and administration which has
our HR folks and helps us with our
Workforce and we've really been focused
on Recruitment and Retention which we'll
talk a little bit about later on our
project development division is a
division that um plans designs and then
oversees the construction of all of our
projects Statewide all of our
construction projects they also take
care of the right of way that the it
that's the land that the roadways our
roadways and transportation systems sit
on um some fiscal year 24
accomplishments include 5 seven new
construction contracts um overall we
provided oversights on 84 active
projects for a total value of $750
million we have our Turnpike system our
Turnpike system is what we call an
Enterprise funded system all of the
money that's collected through the tolls
on the turnpike system has to stay on
the turnpike system so we cannot take
funds that are collected on toll roads
and spend those funds on non- toll roads
so this graphic describes the turnpike
system we have three segments I95 we
have the Spalding Turnpike and we have
the central Turnpike system um or F
Everett Turnpike system that runs up
from Nashua to conquered we also want to
point out that our Turnpike funding has
been relatively flat there's there's a
modest 1 to 2% um increase as the years
go by but that is far from um covering
the inflation that we've seen in recent
years from a maintenance and operations
perspective we have the division of
operations that includes the bureaus of
Highway Maintenance Bridge maintenance
traffic Mechanical Services takes care
of our Fleet fuel distribution that
provides fuel for state agencies as well
as municipalities and some nonprofits
and we have a transportation systems
management and operations Bureau that um
takes care of what we call our
intelligent transportation system and
really helps to manage uh the traffic on
the roadway on a day-to-day basis um we
do ask snow removal on days like today
from our Highway Maintenance bureaus we
have six districts and about 87 Patrol
sheds around the state 87 Patrol sheds
always sounds like a lot but when you
think of about 230 plus towns in New
Hampshire it's one Patrol shed for about
every three towns and the reason we're
effective with our winter maintenance is
because our sheds are located where they
need to be so we have a reasonable
distance to travel to treat the roads
and restock with salt and other
materials a little bit uh about the
highway fund overview so we're always
careful to to say the highway fund is
not the Department of Transportation and
the Department of Transportation is not
the highway fund I think you heard from
safety before us so I think you
understand they they collect those those
funds um what goes into the highway fund
is the road toll which is uh the gas tax
22.2 cents per gallon
13.2% goes into the unrestricted Highway
fund 2.2 cents flows back to
municipalities through block grant Aid
2.6 cents goes to the betterman and 4.2
cents goes to sp sp
367 which was a Tiffy alone that the
department received um to advance the
construction of
i93 and the way that Tiff loan was
structured the department promised um
for the first part of that loan to put
those funds towards to put the the um
4.2 cents every year to the
municipalities into our state Pavements
and bridges we were able to do that and
pay interest only on the loan until
fiscal year 25 which is the year where
we're in as we go forward that the
proceeds from that 4.2 cents now needs
to go to pay for The Debt Service of i93
until that loan is is paid off so we've
lost about $20 million a year there that
we've been putting towards our state
roads and and bridges
um the highway fund is Do's primary
source of funding our operations and
maintenance on State Road so we receive
quite a few federal funds about
$230 plus million do a year on the
highway side more on the Aeronautics
Rail and and Transit side those federal
funds come to us um and have to be spent
on very specific things we cannot flex f
f Flex federal funds towards our
maintenance and and operations they H
all have to go towards the construction
and the care of the Federal Aid highway
system we do take advantage of those
federal funds though to help our
operating budget by leveraging that to
help pay the salaries of some of our
people some of our Engineers some of of
our finance a portion of our our finance
Bureau and so forth uh some of our
construction folks we leverage those
federal funds to help us um pay state
employees salary to reduce the burden on
the highway fund that goes towards our
operations and maintenance it's also
important to to explain that um most
federal programs require a state match
and the State match for most of our
federal funds is between 20 and
10% in New Hampshire we use what we call
Turnpike toll credits for that match
because we don't have state funds or
money in the highway fund for that match
the way Turnpike toll credits work is we
can take credit for the investment the
capital and RNR investment in our
Turnpike system towards the match of our
federal aid program so for instance if
if we do a construction project a
capital project on the turnpike it costs
$200 million and other certain
thresholds are are are met we can count
that as our match to our federal funds
on other projects that that means that's
a a match that does not include cash so
we have to fully pay for the federal
project with federal funds but we're
fortunate to have the toll credits to
let us do that match the next slide
explains um some of the recent history
for the highway fund
revenue and then we get to the slide
that that I believe this committee was
most um interested in the unrestricted
miscellaneous Revenue that the
department receives and the the truth is
the unrestricted Revenue that we receive
is very very small in comparison it's
it's 200,000 to $1.2 million per year
approximately over the last several
years these we get these funds um by the
sale of surplus
land um we get these funds by things we
equipment that's worn out that we bring
to the the white Farm old chainsaws old
things like that um we um regulate some
signs that are within our right of way
there's a small portion of of funds that
comes to us from um the signs in our
right of way also we have a print shop
that makes plans for other agencies we
get a little bit of funds there and also
from junkyard like licensing but at the
end of the day the unrestricted Revenue
we receive is very very
small some of the issues and challenges
uh the department is facing includes
inflation increased labor and material
cost on a lot of our our construction
projects um we've seen significant cost
increases over the last several years um
particularly coming out of of covid
we're starting to see things stabilize
just uh a little bit but it's still
increasing and it's not coming back back
down um we our other challenges include
Workforce vacancies so our current
vacancy rate Department wide is about
24% that means one out of every four
positions um is vacant that's really
putting strain on us trying to get our
projects out for um construction and so
forth paying the bills and and hiring
people and keeping up with our snow
plowing and so forth um that also winds
up impacting uh productivity and forcing
us to prioritize our resources to our
critical areas and for us our critical
areas are all about safety so we make
sure that we we have what we call
volunteers to help us plow snow from the
W during the winter so we have other
people in the department whose primary
job is not to plow snow that have a CDL
license and we set up a a program so
that they can come help us plow snow for
the winter and we work to keep a a
person and every vehicle we have also
have several state agencies that we
appreciate very much that have employees
with CDLs that come to work with us
during the winter during snowstorms and
so forth to plow snow as as
well um the the next chart shows some
information on our budgeted positions so
the top chart on the next page shows our
budgeted positions and what we want
folks to to understand is um for for a
long time and what we show here is from
2002 to present we have a history of
reducing positions so this has nothing
to do with vacancy rate this this top
chart is permanent full-time positions
budgeted positions and we've had a
steady decline in the number of
positions that we've had we also show a
a graph the line there is what we call
vehicle miles traveled which shows the
the mileage of vehicles travel
throughout the the state and that shows
a general increase while we've been
decreasing our head count and then
finally the the chart on the bottom of
that page shows our budgeted positions
our filled positions and also shows you
the vacancy rate trend line and that
green line is a vacancy rate trend line
and what you can see is prior to 2019
and 2020 we we maintained a pretty
consistent vacancy level but during
covid that vacancy level started to rise
and it's continued to rise and just
recently um is leveling out and it's
important to us that that doesn't
continue to rise Beyond where we are
because we we really are stretched thin
the commissioner explains commissioner
Cass explains it very well we work hard
to get done everything we have to get
done but there are a lot of things
behind the scenes that we would like to
be doing and that we think need to be
done that that are not getting done um
that's the overall presentation that
we've prepared for today and I'd be
happy to take any questions thank you
thank you represent elmy thank you I
have two actually totally different from
each other on one of them is I think the
brine
Innovation came
in about eight years ago something like
that uh we're now brining the roads in
Winter as a result we're getting people
going 75 miles an hour or more on the
main roads but
uh it is an incredible contribution not
only to safety but I should imagine to
your
budget to to be doing the brining rather
than plowing real snow so if I could
I'll I'll take a minute to explain our
brining program so our brining program
is a a
pre-treatment that we will do in some
very limited areas of the state to the
roadways before the snow comes there are
very special traff or traffic very
special weather conditions that we need
to have to make brining um available or
make brining beneficial to our winter
maintenance activities so some there are
some sections of 93 from Salem to
Manchester some secondary roads in in
that area
um that we have to brine on to meet our
environmental conditions for the
expansion of of 93 and we we meet all of
those areas we've expanded our brining
program to include
I95 um the Spalding Turnpike and i93
North to to conquered and the the Fe
Everett but we do not brine Statewide
there are a couple other locations
around the state that we we also apply
brine so what we do is go out before the
snowstorm and when the when the weather
conditions are right we spray the brine
on the road and that brine will keep the
snow that initially Falls from bonding
to the pavement and help us to plow it
off um without pack creating or without
that that b creating we still use salt
granular salt for for most of our roads
and during the storm and for storm
cleanup follow H uh I live on the end of
89 and I haven't seen any sign of salt
going down I have seen clean roads right
after every
snowfall so I don't quite understand
what's going on with that but I did have
a another question
back um when Governor Lynch came in to
office uh and discovered that the
Department of Transportation was uh not
had not been applying inflation factors
to the 10year plan for so long that it
was an 18-year
plan on and brought in someone who fixed
that is it still fixed it it is still
fixed so the the last 10-year plan had a
3.2% inflation rate for the plan we're
getting ready to update the plan again
and we we will update that inflation
rate what's important for me to explain
though that goes along to this is we we
have two things that impact the the cost
of our construction projects one is is
escalation one is inflation so we can
apply inflation factors to projects over
the the next 10 years what what we can't
do and what inflation doesn't do is take
into account all of the anomalies that
we've seen and and cost and and we all
know it's a different world since since
covid material cost labor cost many cost
have our exceeded inflation and what the
inflation rate is even at that high 3.2%
level that we carried in the last
10-year
plan yeah on I was attempting to figure
out how much it was going to cost to do
the internal roads inside my homeowners
complex and there is a
uh a
series on the the national
Transportation agency website that tells
you that follows those costs
specifically yes and which made me very
unhappy but on you can't use that in
your inflationary as we do we do and
Danielle can tell you more about what
goes into our inflation calculation but
we use both the the National
Construction cost index and our own
construction cost index where we look
back at historical prices but again
those those are based at on looking back
and there are often anomalies in the in
the economy that that impact things
Danielle do you want to add
anything if you're interested in that we
can certainly provide you with the way
that we calculate um that
information representative
elberger thank you Mr chair thanks for
taking my question um this is just
general information you mentioned that
there are uh airports that receive
federal aid and some that don't could
you just explain why some do and some
don't nodding I'm sorry nodding I cannot
explain that in great detail some are
are commercial federal aid eligible
airports and some are smaller private
airports what what I can do is get you a
listing of both the airports that that
um do take federal funds and the private
airports that are not eligible for
federal funds followup followup so it
sounds like sort of in general terms
larger airports are more likely to
receive federal AIDS than the the really
little ones larger one and airports that
are open to the public so Lebanon for
instance that that Airport's open to the
public that that gets Federal funding
yes okay thank you repr shamberg thank
you Mr chairman thank you commissioner
rodrig uh in what area or does the state
need to address the benefit system to
keep more
employes is there a deficit what you can
offer and what the Private Industry is
offering
yeah so so when we talk about attracting
employees the department or the
department the the state has a great
benefits program from from my my
perspective where we tend to fall behind
is in the the hourly wage and where we
off also fall behind a little bit today
we still have wonderful retirement
system but people starting today need to
stay with the stay a very long time
before they can benefit from that
retirement system um so you really have
to have the The Long View um from my
perspective the it's not a benefits
issue with with our Recruitment and
Retention it's a dollars per hour issue
and it's we all know about the housing
cost and and New Hampshire and so forth
and you have to be able to afford to to
live where you're working
represent
opal thank you Mr chairman and and thank
you commissioner for taking my question
I I'm I'm curious and I'm going
someplace I probably shouldn't but um uh
in terms of our
airports uh beyond the federal funding
that we may that the state may receive
and Beyond
say uh meals and rooms tax revenue that
comes in from the airports for rental
cars cars and whatever meals Flyers are
enjoying um and Beyond the economic the
positive economic impact of say
Manchester Airport are are there any
other
[Music]
direct is there any other direct Revenue
coming
from those airports you know
particularly the larger ones that or or
maybe all of them I I don't know they
come any direct Revenue that comes to
the state either restricted or
unrestricted right so so from the
airports not that I'm uh aware of there
are some airplane registrations that our
division of Aeronautics collects a a
very small uh amount on so um I'll ask
Danielle to to correct me if I'm I'm
wrong but there there's not a lot of
Revenue that comes in and there's also
not much for for State resources that we
put towards airports the funds that we
have that that go towards airports that
that I'm aware of are federal pass
through funds with without much of any
state match um yes that is true it's
mostly pass through funds for for
airports and and the airp the air fees
that the commissioner spoke about um and
those fees are used to help subsidize
some of the airports that don't qualify
for federal
funds and there isn't there isn't a lot
of that I would say a quarter million
250,000 followup Mr chair follow up and
I'm I'm just curious about what um what
dot um what your involvement is with the
public transit on on that side is it is
it mostly regulatory is it I mean what
what is your
role so so similar to the airports
there's a lot of pass through funding so
we're managing the pass through funds
from the feds is is the primary uh role
to support public transit to support
public transit yes thank you
representative ORS thank you Mr chairman
thanks for taking my question so uh you
had mentioned the CDL drivers that are
volunteering the plow I mean are they on
the payroll somewhere else
and so so yes they they are on the
payroll somewhere else and out of our
winter maintenance budget we pay for for
their overtime that they they would um
spend with us plowing snow there is also
an incentive payment that they receive
$5,000 a a winter which is what has
allowed us to have a very robust list of
those volunteers people who are willing
to do that they have to be available 247
then come in when whenever they're
called but as long as they do that they
receive that that incentive and thanks
we we have a about 140 volunteers this
winter we call them volunteers of course
they're they're paid and they receive
the the incentive but 140 people who are
willing to help us out that way that's
how we ensure we have a seat in every
truck with 180 to 190 vacancies and
Highway maintainers it's great to have
those people we would prefer to have the
people who work with us year round than
in re the training really get to know
their their roads real real well and and
so forth um but it works for us
followup follow up so uh dis did you say
earlier that we have drones we have a
drone program in development or we we we
do we have several drones in in the
department um and those are very helpful
for us from an emergency response
perspective so we can go out you you one
of the things we we do quite well with
our Workforce at the department is
responding in times of emergencies but
there's a a big need to um categorize
the the damage and document the damage
that's occurred so we can get FEMA
reimbursement so we can estimate
quantities of materials that we need and
so forth and the unmanned aircraft are
very helpful for us in doing that they
have great
applications um for our construction
projects um to help our our contractors
show people what what's going on on the
on the project as as well they also have
liar capability so that we can get some
detailed survey information from them
and and so forth and we continue to to
look at ways that they can help enhance
our operations very good thank you
representa Bolton
thank you Mr chair um getting back to uh
representative opal's um question about
whether or not uh you uh expend monies
for
transportation and I just want to admit
that I'm a executive director of a
transportation company in Plymouth and
it's all volunteer drivers and we
receive uh what's called dot 5310 funds
that actually pays for trips and
reimburses are not our drivers per se
but we pay them the IRS uh evalu
evaluation for basically um to keep them
whole you know they're not getting any
revenue from it but they're they're
getting now 70 cents a mile which is
actually quite good but I guess my
question is um I'm also trying to uh
start an actual uh Transportation Route
in the town of Plymouth and um it just
seems so cumbersome to go through the
process of getting permissions and I'm
wondering if you might stream line my
request to get a bus going through
Plymouth thank you you're welcome we we
will I will get your information after
the after the hearing representative
representative Brier yeah I just had one
question uh I'm trying to remember how
much uh money does Road uh the road toll
Bureau at safety collect with regards to
jet fuel and Airway
tolls that I I don't have that number I
we can get that for you okay follow up
follow up does that uh does that still
go directly to the Aeronautics uh
division like was my understanding that
was to help fund some of the programs
over there I'm not sure it's not a
question it's not something I've been
asked I I can do the research for you
thank you figure it
out
representative thank you I I found it
rather interesting that you were taking
people from One department and applying
that
entails it seemed to
me uh a large amount of
bookkeeping both on the part of the
driver and of the
agencies in order to maintain the
person's ability to do his primary job
as well as the secondary
job that because of the hour limitation
by for commercial operators even though
these guys are not normally engaged in
Interstate oper operation they're
engaged in operation on interstates so
they get the the hour restrictions which
are killing
people
uh or killing productivity I'll put it
that way not people productivity how
much does it cost highway to do all that
extra bookkeeping to make sure that you
don't kill off the primary job and you
still have somebody on the secondary job
well u i can talk about the payroll
implications so that there is a payroll
implication for that so we have the
Staffing there there is some overtime
charge to that there is some
coordination with administrative
services to make sure that those things
occur um it definitely is more work in
the in the winter time but it gets it
gets accomplished as far as the
productivity of employees I can't speak
to that directly
I would ask if you have
some yes thank you and we agree with you
not an ideal
situation um the people who do this are
first willing nobody's compelled to do
it and they do get approval through
their their supervisory chain of command
a lot of these people's full-time job is
not necessarily driving a a commercial
vehicle they they have other jobs some
of them work for the dam Bureau at Dees
so part of their job may be to to
operate a commercial vehicle but a lot
of them that's most of all of them
that's not what they're doing all day
every day follow
up uh yeah the only reason I I in a
previous life I did uh liability
investigations and fraud investigations
and and such and that came across with a
OTR and was doing a favor for a friend
and he almost got badly screwed because
he was over hours for because of the
friend and unfortunately I was with some
idiot hit him head on at speed so that's
the only reason I asked that I want to
make sure the state didn't have any
liability thank
you um okay yeah we're we're running
late let's take one more question from
representative thank you Mr chair very
quickly uh I want to refer to the uh
page you have Highway fund Revenue
history and this is before my time but
in
2010 and looks like 11 there's a line in
there that says uh $30 red red search
charge of 38 and then 29 and it
disappears in
2012 what what was that yes so so there
has been a long-term recognition and
concern that the highway fund does not
generate a re enough Revenue to do
everything that the department of safety
and the Department of Transportation
need to to do so there have been a
number of what we call one-time fixes
that $30 registration search charge was
a temporary sech charge it was a
one-time fix if my memory serves me
correctly most of of that sech charge
went to Paving our what we call tier
three tier four roads our lower volume
roads um that were not in in very good
shape at at all at the time but that was
that's an example of a one-time fix that
was used to get us through a few years
for a specific purpose thank you
okay thank you very much for today's
testimony thank
you oh yes just one quick I just want to
get it on the record that in fiscal year
26 and 27 the department believes the
miscellaneous Revenue that they'll
collect will be
$200,000 each year yes it's it's very
diff it is very difficult to um
determine how much land will be sold
what it will be sold for ETC and so we
keep that at at a base of that's in line
with your low
number okay thank
you thank
you TR make not of
that we'll now welcome up the um Health
and Human Services Department
sure yeah let's do
that yeah
did you see that sent an email called
that
um yes welcome and if you'd introduce
yourselves of course uh good morning
members of the committee Mr chair my
name is Nathan white I'm the Chief
Financial Officer with the Department of
Health and Human Services and joining me
here today is also um I'm attorney
janelli and I'm general counsel for and
manager of the Department's Medicaid EST
State Recovery Unit
good morning morning yes uh I'm Meredith
tus director of our division of program
quality and integrity for the
Department okay so before you you have a
presentation and if you turn to page two
that is where we'll begin so the
Department of Health and Human Services
we have a number of different sources of
recoveries and other Revenue
and I think what's important to
understand here and Janelle and Meredith
are going to be going into some of the
details and you've probably heard this
from uh some of the other state agencies
is it is very difficult to predict uh
the amount of recoveries that the state
will have because some of this is
dependent upon probate actions some of
it is dependent upon prosecutions by the
Attorney General's office it is
dependent upon Medicade cost reports how
costs have been reported by various
organizations as well as whether IND
individuals that were previously in the
Medicaid Program has passed and so
there's a lot of externalities that
control these and so what we what we can
see from year to year is uh significant
fluctuations so in in state fiscal year
24 which is not listed here we collected
approximately $3.5 million of um other
Revenue within the within recoveries
this year um based on current
projections and we look at this on a
monthly basis uh we're looking at about
2.16 million however one one settlement
or One recovery could quickly throw that
off because sometimes those come in the
amounts of several $1,000 but based on
current projections that is where we're
looking for State fiscal year 26 and 27
um you'll see that we have budgeted
about 3.1 million uh that's slightly
higher than the current budget um but
when we when we prepared the agency's
budget request back in August we we are
given Specific Instructions
and one of those instructions was to
keep those revenues uh as uh budgeted
for the current bym so that that's part
of the reason why you're seeing 3.12
million there even though the projected
for this year is lower um so that's a
very high level of the overview um of
the uh of the different types of
recoveries and sort of some of the
challenges that we do have in in
projecting some of these obviously it's
about $3 million it's not a huge amount
of money when looking at the many other
Revenue sources that this committee
evaluates on a regular basis um and
we're going to start off with the
Medicaid estate recovery just going into
a little bit more detail there because
that typically represents the bulk of
our recoveries and again some years if
you don't have a lot of if you don't
have a lot of medic medicated State
Recovery you can see a significant drop
whereas other years you can you know
with one recovery alone could be a
couple hundred thousand and it could
change that pretty quickly so with that
I'm going to hand it over to Janelle
hi good morning uh as I said before my
name is janeli and I run the Medicaid
estate recovery unit for the Department
I'm also that unit's general counsel
it's a very small unit it's myself as
the only attorney and then I have four
staff members who support the work that
we do on any given year we recover about
approximately at any given time we have
about 2,000 open cases and that tends to
be the total number of recoveries we get
per year the average recovery right now
the 17 average average 17-year average
recovery is just a little over $4,000 at
a time recoveries can be anywhere from
I'm not kidding you two cents to over a
million dollars so it's uh we're quite
busy and every little bit counts so we
try to go after every type of recovery
that we are permitted to by law we have
actually 16 different categories of
recovery the two biggest are from
probate Estates from deceased Medicaid
recipients uh then we also recover from
certain special needs trusts and then
the other one is the other big one is
from leans on which we've are the
recovery from leans that on property
that's
sold that we place during a recipient's
lifetime and it either sold while they
were alive or after we're very very
careful about following the law with
respect to leans and estate recovery we
do not recover under a number of
circumstances depending on the type of
recovery um as you know Medicaid is a
welfare system and we are obligated and
have been since the Inception of weal
the Inception of Medicaid in the early
1960s to recover under certain
circumstances then state law has also
then
built around that and in fact the
federal law I just like to point out
because a lot of folks don't know it and
I think it's important because it speaks
to New Hampshire's history and tradition
um the federal estate recovery law was
actually based on what New Hampshire has
been doing since the
1930s so um when I first started with
the unit our average Total Recovery was
about 4.6 million and we are up to 6.7
million now but we're at about Max
Capacity at this point so just clarify
we don't all those dolls and yes that we
recover on behalf of the federal
government and the counties as well as
the state so a good chunk of what we
recover actually goes to the federal
government and another big chunk of
what's left after that goes to the
counties for long-term care services
primarily so I don't know um do you want
me to go into some more or uh
so the numbers that you see on page two
uh with with respect to Medicaid State
Recovery um projected for this year will
be about $
1.5 million dollar um and and as Mr
White indicated just a moment ago the 26
and 27 numbers we were instructed to
keep those
fixed
um I don't know if anyone has any
questions or I know you're you're short
on time so I try to keep this
briefer I think we can continue thank
you
okay
right do you want me to walk in through
child support okay so starting on page
four child support
recoveries you'll see our estimated at
11,000 um budgeted in the next two years
at 15,000
these are court ordered recoveries of
medical support where Medicaid's made a
payment on the next slide slide five
cost settlements or you can walk through
this all on slide two as well whichever
you prefer Slide the individual slides
have
descriptions underneath the numbers so
however you prefer to walk through
it uh these are cost settlement
recoveries so this is where the Medicaid
Program um on the just the fee for
service individuals and Medicaid
programs let me let me make a
clarification that will apply to I think
almost all of the next few slides the
recoveries that we're making as an
agency are only for our feif for service
population our Managed Care
organizations hold the bulk of the
Medicaid population over 180,000 people
and I think that in feif for service
right now we have 10,000 people fewer
than 10,000 people on any given day so
we have a tiny portion of the Medicaid
population and these recoveries are only
B based on those 10,000 which is why the
numbers that you see are so small the
Managed Care organizations do their
recoveries on their side for their
population so I just want to make that
clarification for you so the cost
settlements here are for outpatient
claims uh based on our methodology we
pay an interim outpatient payment and
then those are audited by Myers and
stoffer and then we settle up with the
hospitals at a later
date slide six uh other recoveries
diabetic supply these these are
reimbursements that we get based on uh
rebates that we have established with
diabetic supply entities slide seven
other recoveries this is simply an
individual uh account I'll call it or
accounting of Prior year related
recoveries and that's just so that from
a financial perspective we have tabs on
what's happening in the current year
versus prior
years slide eight uh the Attorney
General's office fr Fraud Unit this is
the the Medicaid fraud control unit at
the Attorney General's office that
prosecutes fraud for us as related to
Medicaid providers uh you'll see that
our current projection for this year is
around
$75,000 the next two years we've only
budgeted
40,000 as Nathan mentioned early this is
very case specific it absolutely depends
on how many cases they have how much
each case is worth and how long it takes
to prosecute them
uh slide nine the Medicaid Program
Integrity unit projections by state
fiscal year um projection for this year
is at 100,000 and we're budgeted for
150,000 in each of the next two years
these are cases that don't rise to the
level of fraud but there's some kind of
overpayment that we identify uh in our
population and we will do our own
investigations and when we determine
that it's not fraud we will recover the
money ourselves so that's why this is
separated out from the work of the AG's
unit
slide
10 client recoveries so the other slides
were related to Medicaid providers where
we believe there's been an overpayment
slide 10 is related to where there's an
individual beneficiary where we think
there's been an overpayment and when the
recovery has been determined through
some kind of Court prosecution or a
settlement with County attorneys then we
will receive payments these are usually
done in the form of a payment plan um
current project for this year at
27,000 and uh We've budgeted 40,000 in
each of the next two years again I'll
just reiterate this is all very case
specific so it's really up to what
happens in a year how much activity
there is and how much uh it's valued
at slide
11 this is related to individuals in our
fif for service program who are on
Medicaid but also have some other form
of insurance they could have commercial
insurance they could have medic care and
Medicaid has to be the payer of Last
Resort so in instances where Medicaid
somehow paid first we would recover the
money that should have been paid by
another insurer either directly from the
other insurer or in the case of Medicare
we recover it from the
provider and those are the current
projections are at 35,000 um budgeted at
just 6,000 for the next two years as
you'll note there's a note here it's
elevated this year because we were doing
some back billing for from prior years
but that's not going to
continue and the last uh individual item
is third party liability casualty so
accident and Trauma
cases uh you'll see that the current
year is 180,000 the next two years are
only
90,000 this is partly because and I'm
just looking at Tasha Blanchard my
Bureau administrator for program
Integrity to make sure I'm I'm saying
this correctly but this is partly
because we moved uh our PPL casualty
program into the mcos a couple of years
ago so what's happening now is as cases
are settling out we will get fewer and
fewer recoveries on the state side that
there yes and the Managed Care entities
will be getting the recoveries for
they're doing the work for us and
they'll be keeping the recoveries for us
that money the state then gets on the
back end when we do our rate setting for
the Managed Care entities we lower the
amount that they're getting by the
amount of these recoveries so and
they're then doing the administrative
work of of pursuing the
cases that's the end of our presentation
if anyone has any questions thank you
your timing is impeccable it's 12
o'clock but uh we will we will see
whether there's any questions
representative uh
bolt thank you Mr chair um I want to
make sure I heard this right you say
that you deal with um about 10,000 cases
We There are are fewer than 10,000
people in the Medicaid fee for service
program meaning they're not covered by
our Managed Care organizations followup
follow up uh how many were in the
Managed Care uh situation I think we're
around
183,000 right now thank
you representative elme thank you I'd
just like to thank you for the clearest
presentation on this I've heard yet it's
wonderful I'm so glad to hear
it anybody
else okay seeing none thank you very
much thank you thank you
okay that's all we have for this morning
um so we will reconvene at uh 1 pm
and and uh at that time here from the
Department of uh justice thank
you
e
e e
we'll get started again here um and we
will hear from the Department of Justice
uh your your buttons there good
afternoon my name is Warren Cormac I'm
the Assistant Attorney General at the
New Hampshire Department of Justice who
handles the tobacco Master settlement
agreement the
MSA New Hampshire has received an MSA
payment each year since 1999 the year
after the agreement was was signed this
agreement came as the result of a
settlement between the states and the
major cigarette companies the states
brought claims against the major
cigarette companies uh many of which
related to the company's false claims
about the dangers of
cigarettes as a result of the settlement
the major cigarette producers play pay
the states every
year and uh other companies are also
other companies that manufacture
cigarettes are also required to put
certain funds into escrow accounts
to receive a full payment under the MSA
the states must diligently enforce the
MSA and its Associated statutes so
that's my
job since the Inception of the MSA
payment payment amounts to New Hampshire
are regularly in the tens of millions of
dollars annually and that payment
typically occurs in April and in recent
years it's come in the form of uh two
separate
payments the payment to calculate the
payment we start with a large base value
and then that value is adjusted upwards
and downwards several times before being
allocated to the individual signatory
states though it's not the only factor a
major factor which helps us estimate
this payment is the total amount of
cigarette sales
Nationwide when I've previously
testified before the Ways and Means
Committee I've been asked to answer the
following questions uh one what are the
contributing factors that go towards the
annual MSA payment two what are my
estimates uh for how much New Hampshire
will receive an MS payments for the next
three years and three how certain are my
estimates and is it possible to increase
the certainty of those
estimates so first I'll start with what
are the contributing factors that go
towards the annual MSA payment we start
with a base payment that's around $9
billion it goes up for inflation so
that's 3% inflation every year assumed
if inflation is greater than 3% then it
goes up for that greater amount it goes
down for a volume adjustment and that
volume adjustment is the volume of
sold
Nationwide and there can be reductions
in the in the downwards volume
adjustment which means the volume
adjustment can then go up a little bit
um but still be downwards uh due to
increased operating income for the major
manufacturers there's also a downwards
adjustment for the states that are not
signatories to this agreement so that
reduces the amount that the states that
are signatories to the agreement receive
and then uh there's a potentially
downwards adjustment uh for something
called The npm Adjustment npm stands for
non-participating manufacturer this is
uh sales of uh cigarettes that are
outside of this MSA payment structure
MSA agreement they're not signatories to
the MSA agreement and then after we do
all that we allocate New Hampshire uh
New Hampshire's allocated amount and
that percentage stays the same every
year um it's about uh 65% of the total
payment and many assumptions go into
these factors I'd be happy to discuss uh
those in the question period if you all
are interested but it's a complicated
formula and uh it relies on many
variables and uh at the end of it I can
come up with an estimated amount but I
always give the caution that the amounts
that I put in any of these memos are
reliant on a large number of factors uh
most of which are incredibly difficult
to estimate and even if we estimate them
perfectly uh the cigarette manufacturers
may decide just to withhold certain
portions of these funds because they
have a right to do so under the MSA
agreement so these estimates are rough
estimates at
best what are my estimates uh for how
much New Hampshire will receive for the
next three years well 2025 I estimate
around
35,000 excuse me 35 milion
500,000 uh 2026
32,500 th000 and in
2027 30,000 excuse me 30 million um so
those estimates they're around 35.5
million 32.5 million and 30 million uh
are rough estimates at
best and as I said before these are very
uncertain uh a major factor here is that
the signatories to the agreement do have
a right to withhold certain portions of
that agreement of the total sum to be
paid uh sometimes a company will go out
of business or cease to be able to
transact with the United States and in
those cases we won't receive the funds
and there's also the npm adjustment um
which is an adjustment that could also
reduce uh our payment by a large amount
but we have the state of New Hampshire
has settled uh that dispute for the
prior several years which results as in
receiving the majority of that pay
payment um in the
year subsequent to that payment
so I can talk more about that if you
have questions about that but that's
generally how the npm adjustment works
is that there's a slight downwards
adjustment to the total payment we've
settled it which makes it a lot more
secure and that's something that we've
done for the last several
years there's the risk uh that if we go
into an arbitration um it could be
reduced and if that were to occur we
could lose uh the entirety of the
adjustment or the entirety of the
payment but that has not happened to New
Hampshire so very uncertain but those
are my estimates happy to answer any
questions representative
opal thank you Mr chairman and um thank
you sir for that um I'm I'm curious you
mentioned I think
two
um situations in which a a company could
withhold funds from the agreement one is
they go out of business business kind of
makes sense the other is I think you
said if they're not able to do business
in the US I'm not sure what
circumstances that would be but are
there are there other um situations in
which payments can be withheld yes uh
they a company who signat already of the
agreement can choose to uh redirect a
certain portion of the funds uh away
from the payment to a disputed payments
account or uh even withhold it from the
disputed payments account there are
certain incentives not to do that
depending on how likely they think
they're going to be successful in an
arbitration based on this withholding
but they can do it for any number of
reasons it it's certainly not limited to
bankruptcy or being unable to transact
with the United States typically they
would State a basis for the withholding
of the funds under the uh MSA contract
settlement uh or uh and then that would
be taken into consideration uh by a
future body potentially but they can
with withhold excuse me sorry about that
uh they could withhold uh based on a
dispute that they have they just have to
claim it and follow up Mr chair follow
um uh the other uh the other area that
you mentioned was the the potential in
going to arbitration for a a bad
result um does the Hampshire control its
own fate or are we dependent on all of
the other
signatories um not not going that
route New Hampshire and several other
states uh many other states have settled
uh much of the arbitration issue uh that
is a continuing settlement and this is
called the um npm adjustment settlement
agreement
and we're settled through this upcoming
payment year so the April 2025th payment
um and New Hampshire successfully
settled for this npm adjustment uh for
several years um but in order for New
Hampshire to be settled through 2026
there would have to be an additional
settlement thank
you uh representative
elberger thank you Mr chairman thank you
for taking my question uh
the amounts that you're estimating and I
fully appreciate that they are estimates
and that you're not committing in
anything um they they drop by about two
and a half million from year to year is
that something that you're seeing as an
ongoing trend is it specifically related
to these years but can you talk some
more about that please I can talk about
that so um I think that the the first of
all yes it's a trend that we're seeing
and this is a pretty consistent trend
um through much of recent history with
the exception of kind of I can
colloquial refer to as the co years uh
there was a bit of a boom in cigarette
sales during that period or at less at
least less of a decline and as I said
kind of at the start much of the
adjustment much of the ways that that
that original base payment is adjusted
uh is dependent on the volume of
cigarette sales Nationwide and there are
consistent declines in that in those
volumes year-over-year and that's
largely what's accountable to the
decrease year-over-year thank
you anybody uh represent elme thank
thank you do you have any data on what
percentage of the cigarette Market in
the United States is controlled by the
groups that are in the settlement as
versus out
that is a good question and I did not
come with that data um
today I will say that the um npm Market
my understanding is that it has
increased but to get the exact um
numbers on that I would have to I would
have to go back to my notes could you
give it to us uh later I could provide
it to Charles perhaps is best way
anybody
else seeing
none thank you very much thank
you so that was uh yes that was short
and sweet um so we have about 12 minutes
now until our our final
presentation
e e
did not leave um the calendar advertised
this as
1:00 uh only having Department of
Justice and Liquor Commission so
technically I don't have to wait till
1:30 um I'm just going to wait a couple
more minutes though I know a couple
people just went out but we'll start
we'll start in about two
minutes
for
e
e e
all right I think we can get started um
and um please introduce yourselves and
we'll get going okay good
afternoon I'm Joseph mik I'm the
chairman of the New Hampshire Liquor
Commission and with me is Tina demier
our CFO Mr chairman excuse me can you
pull that closer you we can't really a
little closer okay yeah how's that
better perfect okay thank you Mr
chairman members of the
committee so we'll start out our deck on
page two you see the 17 control
jurisdictions in the United States and
uh you'll see the there's some dots in
some of the states which are control uh
counties which are in those states of
Alaska Maryland Minnesota and South
Dakota on page three you'll look at the
three tier system been in place since
prohibition uh manufacturing wholesale
broker and
retail on page
four the value of the three tier
system the real value of the three- tier
system in the United States is product
tracking uh something you don't hear
about much in the United States and
particularly in the control
jurisdictions is uh T tainted alcohol or
methanol contained alcohol but worldwide
in 2024 1,200 people were affected by uh
tainted or counterfeit products and 400
people died and in The Last 5 Years
about 1,200 people have been affected
and 4500 people have died
worldwide so one of the most most
important things of the control system
is just that we track the product we we
treat the product with respect and we
put it in the locations those Outlet
locations are controlled
locations on page five you'll see the
competition our main competitor is Total
Wine in Massachusetts the history since
2011 when governor Patrick increased the
number of liquor store licenses that
could be owned in Massachusetts
there was three licenses for years and
then he lifted the cap from five to
seven 7 to nine and now it's up to 12 so
Total Wine
277 stores in 29 states with 11,000
employees $6 billion doll in revenue and
last year they surpassed Costco as the
top wine retailer in the country since
then they've opened 12 stores in New
England four in Connecticut and in
Massachusetts direct competition to The
Liquor Commission in large scale
something that the Liquor Commission
hadn't experienced prior to that because
of the three license cap in
Massachusetts so on page six you'll see
some national and Global factors
impacting beverage alcohol
sales the biggest thing is uh we've had
an increase in alcohol sales in the
United States for the last 30 years
until 2023 three when across the board
uh we experienced a 2% decline
Nationwide uh that revenue is from sip
source and in 23 24 and 25 they're
expecting a
5.9% decline in alcohol sales across the
United
States these are National and Global
Trends there is some bright spots but
there the the the areas where the growth
is is so small uh that it's really not
affecting sales
nationally so on page seven you'll see
some of the factors impacting beverage
alcohol sales as I've said Dry January
sober October two big things second
bullet is uh for the first time more
Americans are using marijuana on a daily
basis than alcohol last year it was 33%
of the people in the United States over
21 this year it's up to
44% so anti-alcohol organizations have
formed Neo prohibitionists as they're
calling them and in 2023 the World
Health Organization put out a statement
that no level of alcohol consumption is
is safe uh as far as the terrorists are
concerned there's some positive and some
negatives obviously we feel that you
know some of the California wines and
products that are made in the South will
benefit it and there's a possibility
that uh some of the products that come
from overseas will uh it'll be a
deterrent and again those are National
and Global
Trends on page eight the impact of
cannabis uh you really can't have a
candid dialogue about alcohol without
bringing cannabis into play and the
Liquor Commission is not for or against
cannabis but we have to put these uh we
have to put these bullet points out just
so everyone understands what's happening
nationally in the United States as well
as here in New England you can see in
Massachusetts they have 355 licensed
retailers uh they're going to do one
they did
1.64 billion in n in
24 and uh the excise tax or the tax that
they re recognized from that was 272
million you can see Main's licenses 218
217 million in sales up 36% from 22 and
they generated about 21 million do in
tax revenue and in Vermont second year
in 130 million and they've actually had
to pause taking
applications uh for lenses because of
the uh the the rapid growth so these are
the retailers and this is the revenue
that they bring in
on page nine just a quick introduction
to the commission the commission is
self-funded it's a separate fund outside
of the general fund and we use no
general fund
Appropriations are are used to maintain
the Liquor
Commission in 2024 we did
$744 million in
sales and the breakdown of our stores
the amount transferred to the general
fund is net of the administrative costs
and transfers to the alcohol pre abuse
and prevention fund and the treatment
fund granted Advantage Health Care and
we are governed under RSA 176 colon
3 on page 10 just a quick outline of the
organizational
structure we have a,0 employees
full-time and part-time
371 full-time
employees 237 of which are in our
Outlets 640 part-time employees a
breakdown of the office of the
commission the division of enforcement
the division of administration and the
division of marketing and
Merchandising on page 11 you'll see some
basic responsibilities for those four
divisions I won't go through it but it's
there and what those uh divisions each
are responsible
for on page 12 on nextg summary project
our nextg is our D our
d365 microcloud Microsoft cloud-based
system which uh took over our mapper
system at The Liquor Commission which
was over 40 years old uh it's a costly
Endeavor but many benefits will uh will
be seen and are already seen and
efficiencies especially in the years to
come as we get through uh the nuts and
bolts of that system we had just
launched it in April of last year so
we're not even a full year into it at
this
point on page
13 retail outlet locations we have nine
state-owned outlets and the square
footage uh 180 1418 59 least
Outlets
53,000
37 37 of those Outlets have curbside
service which is folks can order their
product online and pick it up at the
curb or pick it up in the store and the
next thing that we'll go into as our
system allows us will be home
delivery uh we have uh the state-owned
outlets listed below the nine
state-owned Outlets that are listed
below on the bottom of page
13 on page 14 you'll see
that the top 15 Outlets uh Garner 40 49%
of the revenue and the other outlets are
51% of the revenue you can see them
listed here 1 to 15 and the outlets with
the asterik are are state-owned
locations uh and they produce 142
million almost $143 million in
revenue on page 15 you'll see since 2012
we've renovated relocated and
constructed 44 new outlets in 35
communities uh some of the recent ones
we've done are der Keen in NASA what
we're working on now is our Interstate
95 north and southbound RFP project uh
that's a whole
revitalization of those programs and
we're working with
um our consultant and consultants and
attorneys on the purchase and sale and
Master development agreement so we can
bring that to governor and Council very
soon on page
16 the goal of the Liquor Commission is
to bring the best products and values to
our customers through a positive
shopping experience bottom line clean
stores safe stores well stocked with
competitive
prices on page 17 some of our e-commerce
work
we get over
125,000 visitors a month to our website
our curb side has brought in 3.2 million
in 24 was up 2.1% increase and we've
done 12.2 million year-to date since the
Inception of the curbside in 2020 and
those three Outlets Salem West Lebanon
and Northampton are the top three
outlets for our website
Ecommerce on page 18 just some quick
stats Instagram over 10,000 followers
Facebook over 162,000 followers and on X
formerly Twitter 7,300 plus followers we
send out seven targeted emails a month
to our consumers we try not to in
inundate them but we try to let them
know what we have on sale and the values
that they'll find in our
stores on page 19 are our group Google
reviews um we've 92% of our Google
reviews are fours and fives so that's
very positive for what we
do and Tina will take you through the
history of the revenue sources thank
you good afternoon on page 20 you'll see
the breakdown of our Revenue sources we
have beer tax and permits uh this is the
30 cents for each gallon of Beverage
sold or transferred for retail sales
then there's the liquor and wine Revenue
which is and also includes accessories
and these are through our Outlet
locations um for the retail customers on
premise licenses which is the
restaurants and lounge and off- premise
licenses is grocery stores and markets
and then the other revenue is um for
licensing fees and uh direct shipping
licensing is about 3.6 million and
direct shipping is about 1.2 million of
that other
revenue on page 21 this is the net
liquor and wine sales to profit we
wanted to show that gross profit is
consistent over the last 10 years at 28
and
29% and on the bottom chart you'll see
that net profit from 15 to 23 was
between 19 and
22% and there is a decline in FY 24 it's
at 177% and this is due to the 10% pay
raise and rate change which equated for
about 9.5 million um between the
full-time salaries and benefits increase
and then the rate changes for our
part-timers in our stores to try and
increase the rates to be more
competitive with the um other markets
and then the expenses associated with
our new software system uh it's about an
increase of about $5 million and then
you can see that total net profit from
1935 to 2024 was 1.6
billion on page 22 the uh 24 sales by
customer type and category just to show
you where our sales come from uh you
have the retail sales that are 71.5% of
our business Spirits is 49% and wine is
22 and then the breakdown for the other
categories with on Prem being 12.4% and
off- premise 15.6% and the accessories
are a half a
percent approximately 50% of uh sales
and our Outlets are from out of state
25% from Massachusetts 10% from Maine 8%
from Vermont and 2% from Canada and five
from other states and then the pie
charts are broken down by FY 24 Spirit
sales by type you'll see that uh the
spirit sales retail is 378 million or
84% and then the wine sales is 169
almost 170 million or
54% on page
23 this you'll see uh the peak in
revenue on the first chart uh during
covid and then the decline that has
followed in the years after and as
mentioned the in the 24 net profit has
decreased because of those expense items
we do have two rsas that govern our
transfers prior to the transfer to the
general fund the first one is RSA
176 uh 15 and that's the alcohol abuse
and prevention and treatment fund that's
5% of our prior year gross profit and
this transfer started in
fy16 at 1.7% and today it's uh 5% and
then there's RSA 126a a colon 3 this is
the granted Advantage healthc Care
Program this um number is determined by
HHS for projected or to provide
sufficient non-federal funding with um
the ability for them to ask for
additional funding if they don't have um
that off
Match and then you have beer tax um
which has been consistent around 13
million but has also declined slightly
in FY 24
so on page 24 this is a summarized
income statement um that shows the FY 24
actual and our 25 26 and 27
projections so you start with gross
profit from sales um plus the other
Revenue minus the expenses to come to
the net revenue on row four which is in
the green and you'll see it's been
pretty consistent um FY 26 and 27 are
project jeed to be 126.2 million and
then in the blue you have the transfers
to
HHS and then that brings you to the
total revenue transfer to the general
fund which was in FY 24 109.2 million
and we're projecting in uh 26 and 27 a
little over 102 almost 103 million in 26
and 102.3 in
27 um and then you have the beer tax
which is 12.5 and then we're projecting
13 million in 26 and 27 to the total
transfer to the general fund and we did
provide the transfer language for those
two transfers so that you have the full
language of that
Authority and then on page 25 is just a
graph of the transfers for the liquor
and the beer that you can see the
breakdown um we also included a pie
chart which is the annual breakout of
liquor Revenue transfers so you'll see
that 81% of our revenue is transferred
to the general fund 10% is to the
granted advantage and 9% is to the
alcohol Abuse Prevention and treatment
fund and we would oh and then we have
our charitable contributions our Awards
and our
accolades and we'll be happy to answer
any
questions uh
yes thank you Mr chairman thank you for
taking my question here
uh Mr Mika do you foresee
any concern that this commission I mean
the ways and means should have about
Revenue with the present tariff
situation that's going to go
on well at this point I I think there's
there's a lot of talk back and forth and
I know noticed that this afternoon that
the president uh and Mexico came to an
agreement to hold them off uh for at
least a period of time time uh we think
that eventually if you know if they're
in place and uh we don't do a there's
not a lot of alcohol that comes through
Canada there is some products that do
come through Mexico but there is it's a
given inake because there's a there's a
glut of wine worldwide there's a glut of
wine in California there's a glut of
wine in in Europe there's a glut of wine
in South America in fact in many areas
they're they're ripping up he and
hectars of grapes to plant other crops
and we have Vats of of wine in in
California just waiting to be bottled
you have a lot of production of brown
spirits in the United States uh in the
southern states Alabama Kentucky
Tennessee in particular and you have the
largest uh vodka producer in the United
States in Tios in Texas so even if there
is there may be some adjustments in
where people are buying their products
and and what uh you know if for instance
if badier or Grey Goose goes goes
Skyhigh then people can buy products
that are made in the United States and
we do have a few products uh here right
here in New Hampshire that are made and
produced here that are very good
products as well so I just think it will
be a tradeoff thank you thank you
representative op thank you Mr chairman
and um chairman Mica I I
know and I don't know how far back this
goes but there was a trend at one point
away from hard liquor into wine um and
it and you mentioned in your
presentation there's now it it would
appear maybe a trend back the other way
particularly for the sort of the
prepared um I don't know what I forget
what you called it but you know sort of
the vodka and orange juice in a can or
you know some of these um and I'm just
curious about those Trends and I am
assuming that the margin on wine is not
what it is
on um distilled Spirits I'm I'm not sure
what it would be on on the the prepared
drinks well the the rtds are ready to
drinks are what you're speaking about is
the is the is it's a growing segment of
the market we carry some products in our
stores a lot of those products are
malt-based beverages not necessarily uh
uh Spirits based so they go through the
beer and wine Hol salers in fact
anything under 6% goes through the beer
and wine wholesalers and then between
six and eight we can dual those products
anything over eight goes to the Liquor
Commission but what we're seeing the the
real Trends are is as the Baby Boomers
age out of the market we're seeing a
decline in covering so the folks for
years that bought in bulk and and put it
away bought bought the case sales that's
why we're adjusting what we do is for as
sales are concerned uh that's a big
that's one of the biggest pieces we've
consistently ran about 7030 spirits to
Wine over the years the markup on wine
is does tend to be a little bit higher
than it does on spirits but because of
the differentiation in the percentage
it's it's it's it's di Minimus because
of the the overall vast amount of
spirits that we do
uh the the biggest piece of the biggest
three things that we're seeing is the
Health crisis because now everybody's on
a health kick and that's that's fine you
know we we understand that but between
dry January sober October and the serg
and general coming out and telling
regardless of what amount of alcohol you
drink it could cause cancer that's a
huge scare for people secondly the Baby
Boomers aging out of the market and
third cannabis those are all three
things that we have to
consider good I follow up follow up um
just a one quick followup and you
mentioned cannabis and and this may be
sort of out outside the scope of this
this particular committee but I I did
hear um driving in this morning a story
on NPR about and you had mentioned one
of the one of the benefits of State
control is the ability to track um the
quality uh and make sure that you know I
guess that was in a more significant
issue as we came out of prohibition um
but obviously Still Remains an issue
today and I'm wondering they they
brought up the issue of doing the being
able to do the same thing for cannabis
and I'm just I mean I'm wondering if you
have any thoughts on that well I I have
to start by saying that the Liquor
Commission isn't for or against cannabis
but any any cannabis that's sold in the
States now until some type of
deregulation is done has to be grown in
that state so there the control is there
so anything that's grown in Maine
Massachusetts or Vermont is what's sold
in that state you can't cross B any of
it at this point there's a seed to sale
tracking system a seed toale tracking
system so that you can track it from
seed to
sale those seeds are given a skew number
when they're planted and that that skew
number follows that product all the way
to the end product whether it's used in
an edible uh or whether it's used in
flower
form thank you representative Malloy
thank you Mr chairman thank you for
taking my question about a year ago I
was
uh was invited to a
uh an a whiskey uh promotion by the
distillers in Ireland a group of
distillers and uh it was a year ago or
so and I'm just curious about these
things do they work do they do they help
these uh companies expand their product
expand their shelf uh in the state are
they effective at promoting their
products to marketing question really
sure we've just done and are continuing
to do we started about a year ago with
Bor beia the Irish trade Council uh we
sent some folks over there to do a buy
some buying of barel
so we have uh exclusive products in the
United States here in New Hampshire and
we're continuing to work with bbia and
the Irish trade Council we've done the
same with Mexico we've obviously done
the same with California in many buying
trips uh over the years uh with France
with Italy uh there's a huge benefit in
these things because what it does it
gives you exclusive products and it
builds those relationships with with
those
uh folks in the wine business the
venters Andor the distillers and it
gives you access to those products that
no one else can have we have many many
many dozens a year of exclusive Barrel
Buys in this state because of those
programs that have been done so I find
them to be very helpful and its
uniqueness consumers are all
about one-upsmanship if you can get
something that no one else has and you
can make it available at your home and
someone else doesn't have it that's a
big piece of of that
world thank you representative elme
thank you um I know you've been having
to try to understand the Cannabis market
for quite some time now do you have
access to any studies that show
whether increasing the use of cannabis
reduces the amount of liquor and how
much effect it would be I have I have
hundreds of articles that I'd be happy
to share with
you it's interesting in that regard I
I've been you know you said one of the
reasons is um all this the negative
about alcohol and you know dry januaries
and dry Octobers at some point and I
don't know if you're seeing it
yet I mean there's not going to be a
surprise when people find out oh
cannabis isn't good for you either so
when those markets start when that have
you seen any of that negativity starting
yet because once it does that could you
know mitigate this decline well I have
to give credit to uh the folks that are
in the Cannabis production world because
only uh 65% of the people who use
cannabis are using Edibles only 30 30
35% are smoking flour so in order they
took that car cinogen piece of it right
out by creating the Edibles to be used
and people are that's what really people
are buying and you have the Millennials
who buy into cannabis in a big way um
don't really buy a lot of alcohol they
buy better than the Baby Boomers but
they don't buy as much and the Baby
Boomers are also now the folks that
weren't able to use cannabis for years
because it was a Al and they could get
arrested and they didn't want that sort
of a black mark on their history and now
they're using cannabis because of the
Edibles and not having to smoke it so
there's a lot there's a there's a lot
going on in that
World um representative Spar uh thank
you Mr chair the on the page uh 21 the
graph there I just uh I was just trying
to understand clarify with may I
understand the gross uh sales of let's
say in fiscal year 24 7389 million and
the 28% profit is after the expenses and
running the
operation uh what is then the net what's
the net one down here so the gross
profit is after cost of goods of the
cost of the product the net is after the
expenses operating
overhead oh okay so the the net one is
both the cost of the goods and the and
the net okay and the expenses of
operating yes and just a
followup follow up yeah the there's 68
retail stores roughly or 65 65 65 and do
you each one of them have has like a
separate p&l and you you you assess
whether it makes sense to you know
continue in one area or not depending on
the pnls yes okay yes that's where we've
done a lot of our um store changes in
con consolidations was based off of the
profit and loss of those locations okay
thank you representative ORS thank you
Mr chairman thanks for taking my
question so are we promoting our liquor
sales across state lines via billboard
and maybe at the same time uh
downplaying cannabis you know
schizophrenia psychosis whatever
or well we certainly are are advertising
our our liquor stores prostate line not
only do we advertise print advertised
still uh in the globe but Billboards
across uh Maine and in
Massachusetts uh and as well as social
media is the biggest platform that we
use as well as radio so and as far as
downplaying cannabis not not not an area
that we're we're touching followup
follow up so when the weather gets
warmer we'd like to see a big uh display
of liquor and alcohol out here on the
front lawn you know big sample parties
we can hold that thank you
I mean to follow up on that are there
are there legal issues with you um
comparing I I suppose then that becomes
problematic because then you're starting
to say well liquor is better than
cannabis and so that that probably
brings you into a
whole difficult situation quagmire
quagmire yeah uh that's a television
program representative elberger thank
you Mr chair and thank you for taking my
questions I actually have one very short
one one a little bit long
um on page 22 can you uh describe what
accessories
means that's the mixers and cork screws
and chachki type items thank you I I'm
not a drinker so I I don't know what all
that stuff is and my next question on
page
13 uh you talk about curbside pickup I
used to run drunk driving
programs and uh so I'm wondering what
kind of checking is being done with a
curbside pickup both from a perspective
of potentially drinking and driving and
also from a perspective of making sure
that the person who is picking up the
alcohol isn't my 16-year-old grandson
for example who shouldn't
be receiving alcohol at all so i' I'd
like to hear about that please sure the
same system that we use in the store is
used curbside
so if you come to you let us know that
you're out the person goes out checks
your ID make sure your ID is valid goes
back in and gets your product and then
brings your product out to the car thank
you
veries verifies the credit card to the
sale as well great thank you thank
you any um other
questions seeing none thank you very
much Mr chairman members of the
committee thank you very much thank
you we're
done well that uh that concludes uh
today's agenda and
um see you all tomorrow and Wednesday uh
tomorrow we will start at 10
o'clock
e for